[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et moi ça t'a ont dès ce soir la ligue
de la rédac il m'a dit que c'est du très
très lourd bien il ya du dossier y'a
quoi il ya surtout d'outils alors vous
avez
évidemment l'ensemble du corps
professoral ici présents d'accord très
bon oui très bien comment savoir red one
tu le connais en fait oui on regarde
tout ce qui a pendant l'année ce qui se
passe dans les coulisses tout ça ma
voiture oui tout à fait il a dominé pour
nana na na na pas eu tout ce que j'ai à
ma dépense à quoi tu penses moi la
vérité la vérité oui il m'a dit tout à
l'heure que les fous de moi sur un truc
essuyé à mathieu et du coup j'essaie de
retrouver le nom de la personne pour pas
passer pour un con mais je leur trouve
pas on est peut-être sur une fin de
carrière de mathieu delormeau ce soir
de bien celle là
avoir la mienne déjà
[Applaudissements]
je te jure avec toi avec mag très bonne
fiction le respect aura duré une semaine
j'aurai battu comment ça va tirer de
très bien très frais aujourd'hui
s'agissant de maximum sur le dos de la
beauté si vous savez on commence chaque
semaine lundi qu alors je sais tout je
vois tout je dénonce tout tout ce qui se
passe pendant les pubs en oeuvre les
magnétos et je réunis tout ça dans une
séquence les loups c'est quoi
alors vous savez compter l'effet rebond
lancement ça quand ça
s'arrête à dire j'ai aucune envie de
passer pour un
candidat ump
et on commence tout de suite avec un
gros clash entre guillaume genton et
jean mais s'il ya des
spectateurs
chami
toi et on retrouve que tu es tirer la
lola toujours à l écoute de ses pieds
l'avant
projet d'accord fera mais
je suis content du bon temps en famille
et au talent d'or nicolas pernikoff on
en a pris un énorme dans ses cales
[Musique]
toujours
mais
millau
et au tout de suite isabelle morini bosc
vous connaissez ma mie peu la côte à
côte deux tubes amie keira
deuxième round autres jean bessière et
guillaume genton badaboum ça chauffe le
loup
ce qui est bien avec matthieu delormeau
s'équiper s'embrouille avec quelqu'un et
où la pêche au juste après les tristes
blanchot et balla gaye c'est plein de
choses pour qu'on prend forcément et on
l'a les dotations et accueillante avec
une
possibilité
très beau
troisième ronde janicot guillaume pemba
boutique la bac à tous
ils chroniqueuse un problème de transit
sur plateau tmp de qui s'agit-il
à la fois
il va bien
votre week-end est le principal défaut
de matthieu delormeau baby tôt et
ensuite la personne se faire une opinion
en fonction des cours de journalisme à
moi une école une école de poids de
ce dernier round entre guillaume genton
et j'en mets siens à banon
si confus avec la révélation la semaine
signée bas mais j'adore
écouter moi mon ami et red hat oignons
mais vous avez complètement après josé
quand même un responsable du pôle its
redouane sangonis house met à la bagarre
enfin la batterie c'est son anniversaire
aujourd'hui non mais on lui souhaitera
pas
s'intéresser au cas de mathieu compromis
avant la pub matthieu delormeau rouleau
et comme sa grande carrière monsieur je
sais tout je vois tout mais en fait il
faut savoir qu'ils grattent l'amitié
avec tous les invités ici est bon
redouane et ça il a essayé de gratter
qu'on veut c'est donner mon numéro un
tout où il veut de tout code de la porte
cyril et vous à la maison vous commencez
à connaître matthieu delormeau s'est
jamais intéressé avec lui non jamais
[Musique]
eh ben c'est mathieu c'est un peu
l'année dé stage cette semaine vont
sauver samy naceri est bien évidemment
il n'a pas hésité à faire son petit
selphy
évidemment que ce qui est bien avec
mathieu sectionné donc jamais intéressé
avec toi il faut le projet il ya 26 août
il faut qu'ils nous appellent en tout
cas mathieu lindon mettre à l'aise les
invités
aucune
[Musique]
somme est également cette semaine
dimanche christian clavier il faut le
savoir c'est l'idole de match
prend une photo je vous aime
il aime il aime c'est toujours apparaît
avec mathieu lamour a appris
j'ai passé
mais c'est pas fini on recevait
également l'humoriste jimoh mathieu on
est
tellement je les aime tellement le
trouve drôle mathieu fan numéro 1 de jim
o c'est incontestable
[Musique]
j'aime aussi
[Applaudissements]
il est très très fort tombola pour un
film ouais bon latorre et
j'adore ce que tu fais je regarde des
vidéos gimet prends mon numéro je te
mettre des invits il m'a dit c'est quoi
ton prénom déjà
cédé formidable servat que non mais
vraiment je serais vraiment j'adore
après j'ai pas gratuit les prénoms je
croyais que c'était redouane serré doina
président du bo jack connais pas tous
les faits ni dans quel film on s'appelle
réseau non mais c'est quoi le nom parce
que redouane c'est connu
partout dans le nord de la france
ben arfa s'en sort tout ce que je dirai
jefo ouais bah oui pour l'instant oui
cette année il ya noël dp flingueurs du
poste qui est au dessus du lot vous
savez qui c'est il en dessous du soleil
cindy vidéo c'est di vizio facettes de
mpp af devait il n'y a qu'une lettre et
bien je peux vous dire que son vrai nom
dans le milieu ce n'est plus fabrice di
vizio mais jimmy punchline
[Applaudissements]
vous savez qu'on peut avoir des têtes
négatif est train fois les galaxies
passionnant période d'incubation donc
vous êtes aussi dangereux mais j'ai
envie c'est ce que tu meures agir là
dessus et m'ont fabrice
non
moi je pardonne j'ai acheté un repas
sanitaires pour moi j'étais petit
j'avais acheté ma liberté en fait sauf
que la liberté monsieur ne s'achète pas
allée touton gratuite
vous connaissez des as pas parce que 38
millions de mac soit mêmes conneries que
c'est pas une connerie
sinon j'adore rouler à 300 à l'heure sur
l'autoroute
est un désaccord vous avez vu les
violences c'est le pari vous voulez bien
évité d'employer des mots doux
comprenait pas le sens
voilà pourquoi ces débats sont sous laon
et 120 selon vous comprenez rien et
sensible alors c'est machado et qu'elle
met vous avec moi
[Musique]
olympia c'est qu'en fait donne un avis
dont on nous manque ce tard il raconte
n'importe quoi
dans la rue un boulot
il y aura un plateau ici et un plateau
dehors avec un de ceux qui ne veulent
pas rentrer c'est comme en boîte de nuit
qui ne veulent pas rentrer et à 10
sur votre trottoir vous êtes tout seul
et vous les gibiers et voulez et vous
verrez que je vienne quoi vous voulez
que je vienne
bref
voilà
incroyable qu'elle d'arc à
cyril est ce que vous pensez vraiment
que j'allais repartir avant de parler du
petit chenapan du paysage de dosettes
français a fait la dernière c'est quand
vous celle d'un magnéto oui il concerne
cyril valery sac à dos d'âne et 23,7 en
1974 à paris est un animateur et
producteur de télévision français
piccone mais votre page de wikipedia ici
tu connais les trois premières phases
elle va cyril ce que vous savez pas à la
maison c'est que pendant les magnétos
pendant les interviews etc il est là et
il perturbe tout le monde sait ce qu'on
appelle sur les bulletins scolaires un
élément perturbateur c'est moche
[Musique]
ce qu'ont expliqué ce qu'est ce petit
outil qui s'installent ici c'est une
table
[Musique]
quel est le but du pass anita mathieu de
jambon y la mettre dans la gueule
ta ta ta ta ta tête autant il va
défoncer la gueule laissez moi finir
ouais pourquoi c'est camus qu'il
écrivait albert
les coûts face société on va faire
société on fait roquefort société dans
les dérives tu peux dire ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné tu peux parler les murs mais
moins bon
[Applaudissements]
regardez je mets mes mains ici
moi ici je les mets dans mon cul
je pas si quelqu'un ici connaît à aps je
pense que personne connaissent
association fait des chansons
on fait des choses
super axes entre 10h mon cher m vous
pouvez vous la mettre d'accord
[Applaudissements]
sama ont fait une belle émission